in 2006 a Nebraska man killed his former  teacher for failing him after cheating  on a test  18 years earlier in 2009 a nurse was  accused of administering a fatal dose of  a painkiller to a patient the nurse  believed the patient had stolen a  high-school boyfriend  20 years before in 2013 a 68 year old  man drove to the home of a former  classmate who had bullied him fifty  years earlier and shot him dead can buy  guns ever really beat by guns  excuse me we went to school together  sorry on him place it Gordon Moseley  Gordo Gordo  honey Gordon when I went to school  together a very long time ago  I believe the bad things from the past  oh they can be a gift  guys odd I think he wants to hurt us for  something that happened about that  the past is not done with you after high  school and some people stay exactly the  same  thank you these delusional thinks that  were friends thanks sir I loved it  dinner dish food you don't find that a  little troubling yes that